montag 9 uhr verteidigungsministerin
klaudia tanner besucht die stellungs
kommission in wien
wir mussten ja aufgrund der korona
situation hat die stellung in ganz
österreich aussetzen aus der
gesundheitlichen gründen die stellungen
werden ab heute mit erhöhten
sicherheitsvorschriften wieder
durchgeführt das ist eine ganz besondere
herausforderung wie wir auch jetzt schon
gehört haben nicht nur was die
ausrüstung auch all derjenigen die mit
der untersuchung zu tun haben anbelangt
die ja nicht nur den mund und
nasenschutz sondern auch zusätzlich das
gesicht soll visier tragen und
handschuhe tragen sondern das heißt auch
dass die anzahl derjenigen die hier
zustellung kommen eine geringere sein
muss um auch die entsprechend
notwendigen abstände waren zu können
so können und uns überzeugen können auch
das wirklich sehr aufgeregt